let's talk about this plan here's we got
one advantage he's coming to us
we have what Thanos wants so that's what
we use we have an incredibly
collaborative team at Marvel Studios
Victoria Alonso seeing us through with
the visual effects and making sure we
deliver the film and it really becomes
an amazing sort of crucible of
creativity and that is the reason I
think the film to turn out as well as
they do is because everyone has this
shared vision of the audience experience
[Music]
so in terms of visual effects when
you're working with IMAX you have to
consider the bigger frame and you do it
you know on a scale of understanding
creatively and partially technically in
terms of what you have to deal with
creatively you've got much more room to
animate in and then kind of consider
what your characters are doing in the
frame in addition to that you also have
to know if you're carrying so much more
data because of how much more resolution
you have in the actual picture and which
ultimately when it gets projected on a
large screen you want all the extra data
for all that extra detail and that's one
of the amazing things about IMAX that
you actually see that oh my goodness I
mean there are so many digital
characters in this we have nine all CG
talking characters so you've got vision
and you've got other ones that we
enhance so nebula vision we will we will
enhance but then you've got rocket Groot
Thanos who's in over 600 shots in this
film so we have not only had to do
enhancements to the live-action
characters but they're digital
performers left and right and Doctor
Strange is beautiful like I like his
effects quite a bit Iron Man's always
fun and in this one he has a bleeding
edge suit so in kind of transform into
anything he wants it to
so for NVIDIA war we knew going in that
if Thanos didn't work the film didn't
work when I'm done half of humanity will
still exist Venice was definitely the
biggest challenge so is something that
we we did test very early for Thanos the
great thing about visual effect work is
the technology continues to evolve so
every couple of years you have more
tools in that toolbox than you had a
couple years ago and one of the things
that we're most excited about is the
character of Thanos we knew he was gonna
have to carry the film and as such it
was it was just a great deal of pressure
to get him right working with Josh
Brolin and having that come through he
just couldn't have been more perfect
because the technology allows for very
very subtle nuances of her performance
to come through so when we showed him
some of the footage he just was warned
he's like oh my god okay he's like I do
that I do that
does put a smile on my face seeing an
IMAX the best way to see it because you
do get to see all this detail that we
put into the characters you know on a
very large frame and in the best part
and you know after seeing it and I'm
actually the first time is all that
detail holds up how does this dude still
alive is not a dude
neuro dude yes this is a man by handsome
muscular man
[Music]
[Music]